hi everybody at film courage hi Karen hi
David my name is Monique Amato and I
just wanted to thank you so much for all
the amazing content that you put out and
just all the work that goes into doing
these interviews and finding the people
to do the interviews and so much that we
all don't even see of what you put into
it I hope you never give up on doing
this because it really inspires the rest
of us and so a couple of the oh by the
way I live in Berlin Germany I don't
know if you need to know that but that
but a couple of the things that I love
most about film courage are my favorite
interviews my favorite videos have been
interviews with Michael Howe and I just
pretty much loved any of his interviews
and I love the way he talks about story
I like the way that he has almost a
spiritual way of talking about it out no
that's intentional but the way he talked
about character arc and about the
character going from their identity into
their essence and I just like his
overall perspective on story
I like the interviews with him and I
think it's mark Travis where the two of
them are giving their perspectives and I
really loved the beginning of this year
you put out that motivation for
filmmakers video full of all these great
short clips of people with amazing
stories and it just it was like the
perfect thing for the beginning of the
year and yeah so to tell you a little
bit about me and how I believe that
you've really impacted me in terms of
just helping me to keep going is I had
this a children's story about a dragon
and without wings and I was encouraged
to turn it into a script last year I had
a half-finished
feature-length at that point and I had
one short
that I had written and but I wasn't
really intending to adapt my own story
hoping somebody else would come along to
do that and but I ended up doing it in a
really short time so then I had it I
started entering it in contest and I was
really encouraged that I got as far as
the quarterfinalist with terrain craft
and that really inspired me for my first
feature script so then I felt really
encouraged I got really good feedback
from them and I had been watching
Michael home and I kept thinking I want
to hire him as my coach so I ended up
hiring him to coach me on pitching
getting better at my pitch for the
script and because I had an opportunity
to pitch to DreamWorks this year so I
got to have an hour with Michael hog
which was amazing and and then also at
the beginning of this year I connected
to a filmmakers network here in Berlin
because I really wanted to get my short
film made into a film and I unexpectedly
ended up directing it which was
terrifying and exhilarating and it's
just been an incredible learning curve
for me and I was all the while listening
to your videos and watching your videos
on directing and just learning so much
that was helping me particularly weave
the ones with Mark Travis and so right
now that film is in post-production and
it's just needing the music to be
finished and then it's ready to go and
so you guys have just they're just I
can't even tell you how many ways you've
affected me and my my my passion for
filmmaking and writing and story so I
just hope that you never stop doing what
you're doing I also love Karen I love
the way that you interview people I
think you're an amazing interviewer I
love the way that you just have this
easy manner you
incredible questions and I've never
heard so many people that are being
interviewed today hmm that's a good
question as when you're interviewing
them and I just think that's a sign of
an amazing interviewer so anyway thank
you guys so much I wish everybody out
there the best I hope that all of your
your dreams come true and I know it
sounds silly but it's not silly because
that's what we're all doing here right
so I really do and I just I hope that
everything that you guys are seeking and
pursuing comes to fruition thank you bye